Justin Bieber makes his first public
appearance since counseling the
remaining 14 shows of his purpose world
tour the sorry singer enjoyed a night
out on Thursday at the launch party for
celebrity stylist Carla Welch's Bieber
inspired collection with Hanes in Los
Angeles the 23 year olds kept it casual
in a pair of pink sneakers ripped denim
a white shirt a black baseball cap
oversized glasses and some stubble it's
super sexy I think that girls are really
gonna like it later Justin met up with
Pastor Chad Beach for dinner at catch in
West Hollywood
the singers night out comes just a day
after he returned to city church in
Beverly Hills with Pastor Judah Smith
one week after he hit a paparazzo with
his vehicle outside of the venue it's
been exciting it's been an amazing
rollercoaster ride sometimes a good day
sometimes bad day that same day Justin
posted a message to his fans to explain
why he cancelled the remaining concerts
on his tour quote me taking this time
right now is me saying I want to be
sustainable I'm not expecting anyone to
understand but I do want people to have
an opportunity to know where I am coming
from
[Music]
you